I'm in a room listening to everything go
on and just hoping she's alive that was
the hardest night ever
140 cups three World Cups four European
championships and 12 International goals
Alex Scott
always allowing me that platform to see
things learn things about the world that
I know was making me even more hungry
and to keep that I needed to keep doing
well at football
and couldn't speak growing up because of
a speech impediment how did that impact
your life there's certain things I I
just can't say but it's almost I found a
habit of just laughing at myself before
everyone else laughs at me here I am
getting nothing but pure hate death
threats and abuse I can't do this
anymore
my dad had this dark side so my
protection was to try and love my dad
all I can and all those darkness and the
demons will go
did that work
[Music]
scared they could ruin my Dad's life
[Music]
before this conversation starts I've got
a favor to ask from you 74 of people
that watch this podcast frequently
haven't yet hit the Subscribe button and
nine percent of people haven't yet hit
the Bell to turn notifications on the
bigger this platform gets the bigger the
gasket so if you could do me one favor
if you've ever enjoyed this podcast
please hit the Subscribe button and turn
notifications on without further Ado I'm
Stephen Butler and this is the Diary of
a CEO I hope nobody's listening but if
you are then please keep this yourself
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
we sit here in East London today yeah
and your story starts in East London as
well
take me right back to
to East London when you grew up in
some when was that 1980 Something 84 84
yeah take me back
well instantly even when you say East
London I'm smiling
because I have so many happy memories
and the feeling that it gave me a sense
of community everyone looking after you
even though it's surrounded by struggle
and hardship it makes me smile
East London instantly I can go to
playing in the football cage because
that football cage was a freedom for me
it was an out it was an escape it
allowed me that football cage allowed me
to start dreaming of a world that I
don't know that I never thought that I'd
be able to see or imagine but in that
space it gave me that when was the first
time you'd watched a football match how
did football come into your life
I don't actually even remember sitting
down to watch a football game on TV
because both my mum and dad they weren't
athletes so it's not a thing that would
sit down and watch a football match but
in that area that I grew up in that
football cage was everything it was the
community it was where people came
together and I think that's how I got
into football and that's what I liked it
gave me that connection to other people
so for me it wasn't dreaming that you
know I wanted to play football be a
professional footballer that wasn't it
at all it was a sense of a safe space in
that football cage and feeling at one
with everyone else in the neighborhood
escapism a safe space
why was that a safe space
a safe space
from a home environment
the football cage
was fun
I could smile you felt free
and then home
it was like
I was locked in
it was
an environment where it was very much
controlled
controlled by your father
yeah
tell me about your mother and father
my mom
a woman that is
an incredible person
full of love
full of softness
and just a light around her
that wants to do everything for everyone
before herself doesn't even think about
herself you know doesn't even see the
person that she is
because ultimately that was taken away
from her
my dad
even though I see the love in my dad I
wanted to love my dad so much I was a
daddy's little girl
but he had this dark side
and that's the side that we saw our
lives growing up
when was the first time you you recall
seeing your father's dark side
I can't put in an age to it to be honest
but I was there
mostly what I can always remember
that you saw this love inside
and I I always say the drink but
obviously the drink helps it come out a
lot more
but I just you could see him turn like
he's thought so what he was going
through in his mind
that's how he took it out on I'd say all
of us more so my mum
but yeah
it was just for me it was just sad
because I could see this good in my dad
that was there
when he smiled when he was listening to
music and that's the side I just always
wanted to see and was begging to to stay
there but it wasn't
in that home was you your brother and
your mum yeah
these memories how old were you when you
started having these memories about this
other side of your father
well he left when I was seven
so from the moment
from a baby from two three
I could see and feel you can feel it the
environment that we're in that you're
not allowed to do something because if
you do step out of line you know what's
going to happen and you don't want that
to happen
what's gonna happen
when my mum would go through
the terror
the helplessness that you can't do
anything
this is yeah
so you're living in fear
you're living in fear every single
moment
and so high then the football cage
becomes your Escape
for me
did you did you want to go home
after school after
yeah
owners go home to protect my mum
I wanted to go home
to put a shield around her
to be strong for her
even though she was doing the same for
me and my brother
but it's like you wanted to protect
someone but how can I
I can't
so my protection was to try and love my
dad
all I can
to keep trying to bring that side out of
him if he has the love then maybe he'll
start loving us in that way and all
those darkness and the demons will go
did that work no
no
he swear because I sit here with you and
then say it is dark and straight away
it's hard for me to talk about
because I suppose I've hid it for all
this time
it's easy not to talk about it
but even though there's so much Darkness
there's so much I remember the good
times with my dad I remember going to
the record shops and buying vinyls and
coming back and dancing my Dad loved his
music I love my music because of that
so there's so many things that
yeah even though all those dark times I
know because of everything that I've
gone through I am the person I am now
you have to take the good bits and the
bad bits and it's what makes me me
you said earlier that your mother had
been she'd had her personality or the
the goodness taken from her alluded to
the fact that it was taken from her
what do you mean by that
because every single day
you see my mum walking on eggshells
she's scared to have a voice to say
something because she knows what she's
going to go through
so that light that is around her and the
woman that she has been that outgoing
personality that you know everyone loves
my mum she doesn't see that because it's
been stripped
she views herself as a coward
where
as much as I try and tell her
she doesn't see herself like that
she's a coward for staying with my dad
for those years for not leaving earlier
for her kids
so as much as
we see errors
an amazing woman she doesn't see herself
like that one bit still today it's still
today
still today
she's she's scared with my book coming
out because I finally told that story
she scared that her friends are gonna
look at her in a certain way
like I said she calls herself a coward
where I had to see the woman
that's so full of Courage and the
strength and the vulnerability that
she's shown her whole life for us for me
and my brother
in the book you you talk about two Vivid
memories you have of that time and one
of them being the day your mother did
speak back to your dad at a joint
birthday party yeah yeah
do you still remember that day yeah
yeah what happened that day
Steven we had the most amazing birthday
party it's hard because there's not many
things that we've celebrated or those
moments and I don't even know how this
party came about whether it's for me and
my brother or is my dad throwing a party
because he was a big character
you know everyone loved Tony Scott he
had this way about him
um but we ended up having a birthday
party in the local community me and my
brother and just yeah the music everyone
was dancing and that's where you I could
see my mum
you know she was the life and soul of
the party just her energy was so
infectious and then party then ended in
the community center we went back to the
flat where I grew up in
and then it was just exactly it's a tone
that I know all too well
that no one else knows apart from me my
brother and my mum when he asked her to
go and get some lemonade
she was in the middle of a conversation
so a natural no totally you get your
lemonade
and it was that icy tone when he
repeated it and she said no again
it's hard because I'm looking at you but
I can see
I can see so yeah
then straight away I know what's coming
as soon as everybody leaves that night
he doesn't forget
so then
we all know what's going to happen
my mum might have been brave enough and
forgotten that moment because she's
having fun she's having a conversation
with her friend
that was the hardest night that one
you know the thing about the book
is we've never had the conversations
so my mum
is trying to survive
for her kids
and then I'm in a room
listening to everything go on and just
hoping she's alive
but she doesn't know
what me and my brother are doing
or feeling
until I've wrote the book
in those moments did you speak to your
brother about it no
you talk about being awake at night
hearing what your father's doing to your
mother
and never knowing if your brother was
laid there thinking and feeling and
hearing the same things
you never looked over at him never spoke
to him about it
yeah
he was in the Next Room I had a little
box room that was everything
and then as there's a silence the next
day
you're not allowed to speak until you've
spoken to that's the environment we've
grown up in
so all you have is a look or trying to
catch a Feeling
and our feeling is mum's alive
that we've still got a mum for at the
moment
when you woke up the day after that
birthday incident that party incident
yeah
and you should I didn't sleep I didn't
wait so yeah
and you saw your mum what did you say
sadness
what can she do
someone so hurt that every time she
moves it hurts
I heard everything I heard her tried to
run
and then so then
as a five six year old
well I just want to hugged my mum
but we can't
you can't hug her but no
why
wasn't allowed to show love
I suppose that's why
I suppose like a word like control is
easy to say isn't it I suppose until you
break it down and understand that's the
control like we're not even allowed to
show love or hug
or speak really
you so the day the day after that
incident you're not allowed to go over
to her and hug her no
your dad has told you you're not allowed
to go in her car yeah
what's the consequences of you if you
hugged her
that time it would happen to me and my
brother
and did that happen to you and your
brother yeah if
if we spoke back
if we didn't obey orders
if you show love emotion you're not
being strong you're not showing that
you're strong right
just get on with things last night
happened you just get on with things
when when you look back and you've
talked about this in your book as well
about how in many respects that served
you becoming a football player and it
made you a little bit more I guess
resilient shall I say
um but when you look back at those early
years and you see how emotion was
disallowed or squeezed out of you are
there were there words spoken that told
you emotion was not a useful thing or
was it just actions and behavior where
did you where did you
lose that sense of emotion and love and
affection and for me I always had it I
know from a kid I just wanted to give
love okay or see the light in someone I
wasn't getting it from my dad or my mom
was showing me in a different way I know
I wanted it I was craving it I remember
my best friend Regan going around to her
house and they're Huggers everything's
so affectionate it's even I would like
freeze like this she'd hugged me and I'd
just stand there like oh my gosh I don't
even know what to do what happens in
this moment and she laughs about it to
this day
and still to the same it's hard you know
I don't hug my mum
like I want to the other day it was her
birthday I was like all right mum little
hug and pat on the back love you
and then like she feels awkward I'm kind
of awkward because that's how we've
grown up we don't know how to do that I
find it easier now because I've gone
through the process of learning that and
that it's okay
but then when I go back into the
environment to this day I don't I can't
I don't think I've ever hugged my
brother
because that's still that environment
it's hard because
for me I feel so lucky I've you know
this career football now in broadcasting
I've traveled the world I've educated
myself in such a different way surround
myself with people that are affectionate
I love that I love giving love to other
people and then I go back into that
environment and straight around like
this again it's like that Frozen
and it's hard because I've been on the
journey doesn't mean you're ready for it
that I can try and bring it out of you
or I can baby steps but yeah
and I guess that environment is still a
trigger so you haven't
you haven't recovered in that
environment yeah you know it was so I
for me it's kind of happy but it's so
interesting also is my niece lives with
us we've had her since she was two
living in some with my mom and my
brother at home in East End she gets it
all and I see that through my mum
through my brother for all the love that
they didn't have or the hugs they give
it to her which is beautiful like you
said but they still can't do it amongst
themselves that makes sense the other
the other moment you talk about in the
book is the day that um
your mum told your dad to leave yeah
yeah she said she found it Inner
Strength Manan had recently passed away
um sudden
and it was hard for my nan this story
from my mum
um because she knew what was going on
even that wasn't spoken about your nan
knew what was going on yeah
um and then yeah as soon as she passed
away a sudden heart attack my mum found
her strength to say no that's enough's
enough
um
and she finally told him that that was
it she said to me she was Finding ways
she'd gone to someone like a homeless
shelter or something to see if she did
run would she be safe and then would
they be able to then collect us
afterwards so she was trying to find
ways to leave the environment but she
then always couldn't because it came
back to me and my brother
and then yeah that day she finally
enough was enough
said she just didn't care she didn't
care what would happen to her or
whatever but she knew that this couldn't
go on anymore for the sake of me and my
brother
did she tell you what she said to him no
I just remember getting the shout to
come down the hallway me and my brother
marching down and then waiting for an
order or something and then him saying
that we had to choose
that he was leaving and we have to
choose there and then right then whether
we live with mum or live with Dad
and me just looking at my brother like
what and he's making us choose like
right then
and I knew something had gone on because
mum's got her back to us so obviously
something had happened on her face or
because she couldn't look at us
it's a pretty disgusting situation to
put children in isn't it to get them to
pick a parent because regardless of the
and you talk about this as well in your
book is regardless of the the abuse you
still love yeah both parents right yeah
there's my dad
like I say like I see that like this
smile or how he is and how can I feel
just sad like even to this day when I'm
thinking about him I'm just like
you know I suppose he's just sad
I don't want anyone to feel sadness you
know
so I remember in that moment like I was
always it's always my mum I was always
going to pick my mum but it's the
thought that my dad would be lonely as
well
how do I have why do I have to choose
like
in that moment would you have chosen
for things to stay how they were
hmm
no no
so you would have chosen to just go with
your mum yeah yeah but it was just
trying to process as a seven-year-old
that my dad might feel lonely and what
happens to my dad
but no I need to protect my mom I need
to be strong for my mum I need to look
after her
hmm
and then your dad's leaves he's gone no
just leaves leaves with everything
Furniture everything not that we even
had a lot to take but it was still just
you know you make do you get by but yeah
he took everything Mom let him take
everything too
because then he didn't have a hold over
her anymore
oh yeah
and you stayed in the house we stayed in
the house yeah
what was life like beyond that point
I think that's why I'm so lucky Stephen
I had football
I had that out I had something to focus
on
you know so I'd Escape into a different
environment that gave me structure
where I think for my mum and my brother
it was it was a lot harder
you know you're still processing my
brother
and I suppose this is where it hurts my
mum
because she puts a lot of blame on
herself
we went from a controlled environment
which very much I was still in control
but a disciplined environment with
football is very different
and then so my brother totally went the
opposite way
for someone that had been controlled and
in that environment
he then had a freedom
but he didn't know what to do with that
freedom my mom didn't know what to do
with him so I think it was harder it's
been a lot harder for my brother
when you say it's been harder for your
brother what's what does that look like
in reality
that I'd say even to this day he doesn't
know himself or what to do his purpose
carrying guilt
you know we talk about strength and
stuff is I know it's very different for
men him feeling that he should have been
that protector
maybe you know
when he looks at his baby sister I've
managed to make a career or do something
and he looks at his life and what has he
done
do you have these conversations with him
no we we can't we've not had a
conversation about anything
as a family we can't sit down we don't
know how to
there's not been a conversation
about anything are you close
in a different way
you know when you hear stories of
brothers and sisters and like that love
we have for each other
is so strong
but in a different way is protect him
from afar
would do anything for each other and be
there
but it's not a pick up the phone how are
you sis what's happened what's going on
in your life
but no matter what you'll just always be
there for each other what do you think
that is why do you think there is such a
distance
because you don't know how to
communicate
we don't know how to talk
when all of your life
from all those age that age Gap when my
dad was in the house
we didn't learn anything
I've gone away from that and taught and
educated myself differently
but my mama and my brother's still been
in that
I felt a bit guilty actually because I
remember going to therapy learning all
of this learning my behaviors learning
then to deal with my emotions and talk
and they're like great go and do this
with my mum my brother you know we'll
start opening the conversation
but then actually it took my mum back to
a place that that hurts her
you know and I did that
because why oh because I was ready
you had you had a conversation with her
post therapy and it hurt her yeah it's
bringing up all the stuff that's still
so Raw
that she's never dealt with you just got
off with life it's what you do right
let's put a plaster over it you get on
with stuff the mentality
get your head down and get through
things but actually you're not dealing
with it are you it's still there it's
still raw
and it will show up it'll rear its head
in very ugly ways at times if it's
unaddressed because it's still
controlling you it's just controlling
you from like the back room somewhere
that's what I almost think in terms of
like domestic violence and what goes on
I think we deal with a lot of stuff till
when the person has left the environment
right but then a lot of the work needs
to start afterwards also
like those conversations actually
dealing with those emotions what next
instead of like oh they've gone can get
on with life actually you can't because
it's still there it's inside
were you ever jealous of other families
no you won't never jealous no I was like
I feel I'm lucky I've had everything for
my mum I've had the love
they care her doing everything she can
you know so I've never looked at other
families and I feel lucky I've been
invited into families that have shown me
love or taken me away and had that but
ultimately for me my mum is absolutely
everything she's done everything she can
I won't be here this person right now if
wasn't for everything that my mum has
done for me in my life
comparison can sometimes make us feel
sad though because it's uh what
comparison does is it gives us these
kind of false expectations of how our
life is supposed to be going so we look
at another family and we oh look at
Christmas they're all sat there and
they're all they're dancing around the
table and they've all got their little
crowns on their head and you know and
then we look at our lives and go
you know maybe
I wish I had all my family here and we
could we could have these moments you
ever felt those kinds of things I know I
have
I spend I spent quite a few Christmases
on my even in the last couple of years I
think last year I was alone on Christmas
people don't really know about that but
I was but because my family is quite
dysfunctional
so getting them all to be happy in the
same place is not such a simple task
yeah so sometimes it's just easier I
think I just flew to Portugal on
Christmas last year you know it's so
interesting you say that because I find
myself removing myself from those
situations that I feel uncomfortable
with
so same thing Christmas I want to escape
because for me it reminds me of sadness
so it's not comparing to other people's
families and the happiness and
everything for me it reminds me of
sadness
so then I'd rather remove myself travel
away be away in my own thoughts then sit
for it and see my mum's sadness
something that I can't change in her
it's like as if I'm still failing to
make her happy in those moments and
that's hard for me so it's never
comparing to other families it's just
that
I feel helpless in trying to help my mum
that hurts
have you always seen that as your
responsibility to cheer your mama to
keep her happy because you talked about
rushing home from school to try and
protect her and
and now now that you feel like you're
failing her
I don't know if I've like ever thought
about it as a responsibility I don't
know I think it's just something that's
me that I've always I'm a helper I want
to help people I want them to be happy I
want to do everything I can for someone
to bring joy to them I don't know maybe
it's because the upbringing I didn't
have much of that or something I don't
know
so I haven't I don't know I've not seen
it as a responsibility but I just I want
her
to have a life that maybe she's missed
you know and bring her that light back
in order to do that she's gonna have to
confront some of the things that bring
the pain back as well though right so we
see it so many times in our friends and
and people that you know they've been
through something you know it's holding
them back from living the fullest life
they could live today but in order to to
unlock that fullest life they have to go
back through some stuff and bring it out
into the open and you see I see it
sometimes with my friends where
I know they don't want to go back there
yeah but if they don't then they're
gonna there's a risk that in my view and
who's who the [ __ ] am I to tell them
about their lives but they're going to
end up missing out on the like the
fullness of Life yeah so it's this
battle it's like do you want to keep on
keeping on and just keep it in the back
room
and live a live a less full life or do
you want to go back there and do the do
the hard work to try and unlock your
and it's a battle and it's like a fit
yeah well what is it
face to face see the fear and face it
and do it anyway like I'm of that
mindset like it might be scary but I'm
still going to do it I'm still going to
give it a try but then I suppose
everyone doesn't have that mindset today
like in order to move forward or see
into the future you can't if you're
still driving looking in the rearview
mirror like not dealing with all the
past stuff behind
and then so for me I think I've got to a
stage like why am I talking about this
in a book or you know it's been hard for
all this like I've hidden it how long up
till now
I've never spoken about my upbringing or
what's going on in my life until this
book until this moment
why was now the right time
because I think I'm
I've learned a lot about myself I'm
older I'm Wiser and
I'm
don't want the heaviness of it anymore
you know and I actually ultimately wrote
it hoping that my mum it frees my mum
you know it's part me but hoping that
this finally frees my mum and she can
move forward from it all now I'm okay
you know Ronnie's done okay for himself
you don't have to protect us anymore
like let us look after you you're an
amazing woman
when you write this book and you're you
know your mum knows that you're going to
be sharing this with the world what are
those conversations like to
as I guess at some point you might have
had to read this book to her or tell her
about the certain parts she read it oh
she read it yeah
she yeah
I'm being just a biased mum but she
loved it
um but she found it super interesting
because once again
I've gone through a lot of stuff
that I've not spoken to her about that
she didn't know about me because once
again I've always been trying to protect
her
so when I've gone through stuff my first
thing is I can't tell my mum because I
don't want her to panic about me you
know she already been through enough so
I can look after myself so her reading
stuff she's actually learned a lot about
me my emotions how I deal with things
that have come up
and an outing like I said that
when she was going for all of that stuff
with my dad she didn't know what
I was in the room doing that I didn't
sleep once because I'm listening just to
make sure that I can hear her move in
the morning
heaviness
use the word heaviness you didn't want
the heaviness anymore
yeah
what is what is that what was the
heaviness
carrying all of this not speaking
about what went on
hiding it every time I'm asked about my
mum or my dad in interviews
because I think if you look back at
everything that I've done as soon as
this topic is brought up about my mum I
get emotional
because straight away someone doesn't
know just talking about my mom and me
saying oh it's amazing straight away I'm
picturing everything that went on
that why I think she's amazing
but I can't tell you that you just hear
me get emotional and then I change the
subject
but like I said I suppose through
learning how to communicate better and
understand my emotions
I just want to be free like I want to be
like I want to move forward in my life
not having any of it anymore like I'm at
a stage in this point in my life where
I'm ready to enjoy this stage this next
season
you know
use the word earlier on patterns what
was the symptoms of that heaviness
how did how did you start to see it
manifesting in your behavior
shutting off from life
shutting off from dealing with emotions
pushing them down not letting anyone in
to help me when I need help
not talking to anyone just I'm always
okay just carry on what's next what
happens next yep I can do that I can do
that doing everything for everyone else
around me but actually I just need
someone to do something for me being
like okay you offering help I'm gonna
say Okay instead of saying no to
everything because I can deal with
everything
which ultimately that's where people
talk about me and the trolling
and you know the trolls pushed me into
therapy no they didn't
you know it was just that stage on top
of every single other thing
that I finally was like I need to talk
to someone this is all too heavy for me
to deal with
like I'm in a dark place
and I can either carry on in that dark
place or actually I can do something
about it this is post your footballing
career yeah went into broadcasting it
was a lot a lot of events had happened
in my life I didn't even know until I
wrote down in a book like a timeline and
I'm like [ __ ] I wonder why I bloody
ended up in therapy because I hadn't
dealt with any of it I just kept going
you know that's been a mentality and a
trait that's the pattern
I'm okay Alex is always okay
quick word from one of our sponsors I've
got a tip for all of you that will make
your virtual meeting experiences I think
10 times better
as some of you may know by now Blue
Jeans by Verizon offers seamless high
quality video conferencing but the
reason why I use blue jeans versus other
video conferencing tools is because of
immersion their tools make you feel more
connected to the employees or customers
you're trying to engage with and now
they're launching one of their biggest
feature enhancements to impact virtual
events so far called Blue Jean Studio I
actually used it the other day I did a
virtual event using the studio which I
think about 700 of you came to TV level
production quality all done by one
person with very little technical
experience on a laptop so if you've got
an event coming up and you're thinking
about doing it virtually check out blue
jean studio now let me know what you
think because I genuinely believe I know
this is an advert and I'm supposed to
say this but I genuinely believe it's
the best tool I've seen for doing really
immersive simple but high quality
production virtual events
quick one it's so crazy that in the last
couple of months I've had so many people
tag me on Instagram even on Telegram and
in my Twitter DMs in a picture of them
starting their heel journey and it's one
of the most amazing things in my life
that I get to do a podcast which of
course needs money to to fuel and I have
a sponsor like you who I genuinely
believe is going to help every single
person who starts their heel Journey
change their life because this podcast
the central intention of this podcast is
to help people live better lives and we
get to sit here and I get to promote to
you a product which has not only helped
me change my life but it's going to help
millions of people and is helping
millions of people live a nutritionally
complete life it's so it's such an
incredible product and for me the reason
why it's incredible is because it gives
me my protein it gives me my vitamins
minerals it's plant-based it's low in
sugar gluten-free it does all of that in
a small drink that tastes good there are
other products there's Foods there's the
hot and savory collection many other
things but for me this ready to drink is
the absolute savior of my diet
throughout the week where I'm moving at
such Pace look I don't want to labor the
point but if you haven't tried he'll
give it a try and if you do tag me
Instagram wherever you try it give me a
tag anyway
back to the podcast one of the things we
didn't talk much about yet is um
which I think would be a surprise for a
lot of people is that you couldn't speak
for for many years growing up because of
a speech impediment yeah this matter
talking to you chatting away yeah yeah
and then working in broadcasting but
when you know
speech impediment is is something you
know you've gotten over the speech
impediment and you went to like speech
therapy from what I understand yeah the
thing that's probably you know I assume
would stay with you for life is how that
makes you feel about yourself in a you
know what I mean because it's you know
you've over overcome it but the the
thoughts of
um struggle or maybe like not fitting in
socially or being a bit insecure about
things can can lingle long after the
the solution's been found when you look
back in your adult years has did that
impact
your life
how other people viewed me I didn't feel
like my voice was important or I
wouldn't be able to get what across what
was going on in my head it's now you say
I'm over I'm not
like it's just I I can hide it a lot
better or I know that okay I have to
reword things or I memorize scripts for
instance or I'm practicing them so when
I get on camera I know that word that's
coming up I can't say I've practiced and
practice it but then I go to say and it
still it doesn't work because I just
can't articulate where the words come
from
um even earlier today before I was
having a juice in and I asked if there
was I can't even say the word cinnamon
or something
whatever the spices in it are there's
certain things I I just can't say but
it's almost I found a habit of just
laughing at myself before everyone else
laughs at me or then just not finding my
voice not speaking out because I'm
scared
that it won't come out the way that's in
my head I know like my brain works so
fast like I'm always thinking 10 steps
ahead of everybody else but I can't get
it out
how bad was it for people that might not
understand what it's like to have a
speech impediment when you're younger
foreign
because you go back to the environment
that I I grew up in it was actually then
easier
for it not to because you're not don't
speak until you've spoken to just easy
not to speak
so which actually then full circle then
my mum didn't detect it till later on
because then I just wasn't speaking
because it was in that environment where
I wasn't really playful or speaking out
anyway
um so it's not until then and then
having to recorrect it but then I'm in
an environment with someone who I'm
sitting with and I can feel like the
love or they're caring for me so then I
think it's just a game right that I can
feel something from you that you're
invested in me which is totally
different to that what I'm feeling of my
dad so then you go back to those
patterns I feel like that's the pattern
that I then craved with everyone I then
just want my first coach to see
something in me I'll do everything for
you just believe in me like I want to
feel that from you relationships the
same thing it's like I'm always seeking
that from what I wanted from my dad I
suppose in my childhood
difficult to have relationships when the
first model of Love you've ever you
witnessed was deeply
um toxic
yeah that the speech impediment so not
knowing how to communicate or speak
properly instead of
what I'm gonna what I'm trying to say
doesn't come out right
so from the speech impedance it's just
easier not to speak
a lot in my circumstances that's how
speech impedant for me Works which go is
crazy because like you said do that for
a living now yeah yeah how does that
work out
because the thing is like on TV I
suppose I don't think about the millions
of people watching me or that for me
it's just always I'm so interested in
the person sitting opposite me because
I'm learning you know the area of East
London that I grew up in I didn't think
I'd be surrounded by people that view
the world or I've seen something in a
certain way and I'm just sometimes I'm
not speaking like hey you you ask a
question and you wanted me to speak so
the same thing I can ask you something
and you're telling me this amazing story
and I'm just sitting there even though
I'm presenting I'm just amazed because
I'm just like wow I'm learning something
here so ultimately yes I do it for a
living but now I'm just sitting there
learning and only speaking sometimes
really even though it's on TV but like I
said in relationships yeah I know that
pattern of not speaking or when
something's tough I would run away from
it
like I have to just push it down push
the emotions down the next day
everything will be fine I'll carry on
like nothing ever happened which for my
partner has always been the super
hardest thing because they want to talk
about it and get it out and all the
feelings
but then I was always scared how those
feelings or if you got to that angry
state
what would happen because I grew up
seeing that in my dad
so then I just want everything to be
great like fine everything's fine
tomorrow everything will be great that's
the thing in relationships you've got to
battle it out to resolve a problem and
if you don't it ends up being deposited
in the relationship as resentment or
contempt and it just stays there as an
issue and addressed yeah and then it
will pop up some some other day yeah
I think that's everything that happened
to me up until I went to therapy is that
it finally all needed to come out
everything
to deal with the emotions the childhood
the speech impediment hiding it all
I've come to learn I remember saying to
my one of my friends last week I said I
think I think the single most important
thing in any relationship
um if it is to last especially romantic
relationships is conflict resolution
because you know I see you I've said
this before but I see relationships as
like imagine two dots and a piece of
paper and then the relationship begins
and they become these lines moving as
the relationship you know carries its
course and then there'll be things that
start to make the lines deviate from
each other and go a bit when but
conflict resolution keeps the two people
close you know if you know your partner
you don't like the way he eats that
thing yeah you can talk about it and
that's a trivial thing but you can
resolve things and keep yourselves close
when things go unresolved it seems like
these two parallel lines start to
deviate and you move further apart and
then you're not having sex but you you
don't know how to talk about it so they
just continues to deviate for so
conflict resolution seems to be the
thing that is
um keeps contentment out of a
relationship which Dr professor John
gottman says is the number one killer of
relationships but it also Keeps Us close
if you're if you're not a master in
conflict resolution it must be quite you
know because you you want to avoid
conflict entirely and that or you don't
know how to communicate in a way that's
going to help you to resolve the
conflict it must be difficult
I say difficult but then I would just
always find a way of question and
obviously is not right which I've now
figured out about myself I would change
things I would stop doing things okay to
try and make my partner happy yeah so
I'm then changing myself I've not been
my true authentic self because yes I'm
avoiding the conflict and everything but
in doing so I've stopped doing what I
want to do or what I like just to then
always keep everything nice and happy
and then you'll resent that's where the
contempt shows up because you think [ __ ]
I'm not doing this for you and I'm not
doing this
but then I wouldn't even speak about
that yeah so I'll just sit there silence
like why am I mad what's going on in my
head like why am I feeling this what's
going on yeah because I've changed and
I'm doing everything just to try and
keep being happy
and you've solved that I don't think if
you'd ever solve anything you I'm
learning you know it's interesting what
did I hear the other day about you know
we spend more time as people studying
other people what you wear what you
study how you act how you behave then
actually spending time studying
ourselves and so I would say over the
last
two and a half years or since going to
therapy
I'm studying myself more so those
patterns those learning how to
communicate better or what I do
which will then help me in a
relationship
moving forward
hopefully
when you look back at your football
career yeah
big smile on your face
um a really really amazing career
um you're very much considered a legend
in the game why do you think you were
successful
at football when you look back what was
it about you and your character that
separated you from those
you know thousands hundreds of thousands
of other people you were competing with
to play for England or to play for
Arsenal
I think it goes back to the cage first
of all
for me football was just always and it
was a escape and a happy place
and I was scared to always lose that
so I actually yeah even though like I
went on what 140 caps for England and
then there'd be people like yeah you're
the first name on a team Sheet you're a
favorite I played every game for England
kind of with that fear that could be
taken away this could be my last game
like what if I don't get picked next
week what am I going to do like it's all
I've ever known in my life
I know I wasn't the most talented
like I wasn't there was people that were
supposed to be at the top and make it
they were the next best thing in women's
football no one ever spoke about me like
that in terms of growing up in the
Arsenal team I was oh I was an owl that
grew up in East London you know I loved
Arsenal that's how everyone viewed me I
just loved the club you know because for
me it was a home
but no one ever spoke that I was going
to make it
but I suppose that's where
I just wanted people to believe in me
you know
so I was like how I would do everything
to prove to you you know I've got
something just look at me I've got
something I love this place
so I think it was driven by that really
and a feeling of not wanting to let
people down even though they didn't
believe in me
how did that manifest in terms of your
training and your your performance and
your preparation and your direct guess
at your obsession
trying to be the best I can be every day
in every training session every training
session like I've been given an
opportunity
how dare I turn up to training and not
leave giving it my all or coming to
train and be like I don't fancy it today
like I'm so lucky I haven't come from a
council estate or a concrete football
pitch and now I get to walk in at
Highbury or be at the Arsenal men's
training ground you know it's like
who am I to be like now I don't fancy it
today
like I just I just loved what he was
giving me in my life
it's funny we often think of we ask
motivated people we say how do you stay
motivated and when you you look under
the hood it tends to be a
less of a choice than we think in the
sense of it's not like I'm waking up and
going I'm going to be motivated looking
in the mirror and going come on we've
got this it's more it's more sometimes
as you've described like an escape from
something else like yeah and we don't
think of uh motivation as escapism all
the time or insecurity but it so often
is yeah I just knew what football was
giving me in my life
something that you know I had dreams but
never dreamed that I'd be able to travel
the world or you know I remember in the
youth age groups getting on a minibus to
go into Nottingham you know like where
is this place didn't even know this
place existed in the UK you know and
here I am on a mini bus seat in a
sandwich for a packed lunch you know
I've been out the house all day it's
like great I didn't want to let go of
that
playing for England I got to go on an
airplane I got to go to China what oh my
gosh I didn't even know how many hours
on a plane that was you know all those
things were just feeding more I knew it
was more than football but football was
allowing me that platform to see things
and learn things about the world that I
know was making me even more hungry to
keep it and to keep that I needed to
keep doing well at football
and you end up retiring what 33 34 you
quit the international team at 33 quit
Arsenal at 34. if football was giving
you all of all that you've described
there
how did it feel to come to the end of
your time with Arsenal and the England
team
I was learning more about the world and
from other people
and actually then I knew towards the end
of my football career
it was giving me those feelings that I
didn't want the heaviness
and actually a feeling this is not
enough for me anymore
not a feeling of being trapped trapped
is the wrong word
but there it was it was Heavy towards
the end of my career I was taking on a
lot of emotions responsibility I was
Captain
but in terms of I don't know I've always
been this person whereas people can
offload all their emotions on me so I do
that I'll take that home I try and solve
a lot of problems on and off the pitch
and I just I wasn't happy anymore
in my last couple of Seasons well I
didn't know I remember doing a
documentary about Mental Health
and the doctor um Tyra Tanya Byron is
her name
she described it to me so well I didn't
know I was like a functional depressive
this whole time and that started in
those later years of my footballing
career but I didn't know I didn't know
how to describe it or what I was feeling
you know I was just turning up I wasn't
happy it was Heavy taking on everyone's
emotions management players trying to
fix everything and then I'd be home in
the evening and be like whoa I don't
want to talk to anyone like I physically
couldn't talk to anyone which of those
patterns then I'd swish off from the
world
if you try and phone me call me won't
pick up mum yeah I'm okay don't want to
have a conversation because everything
was just then heavy no one in football
knows that because I could go to
football I'd put on a face like I'm Alex
like yeah everything's great leader
Captain great
but then I knew I couldn't do it anymore
I did a TV show Bear Grylls and that was
the first time I knew I was ready to
retire from football
I was surrounded by different people
different conversation about life other
than being in a football bubble where
everything you're consumed by and you
think everything's just sport going on
in the world where I know I've always
needed more
I know that's what's always been the
spark in me about life
and it was the first time I started
having conversations about the world
about other people's lives I'd sit under
the stars it sounds like some Hollywood
movie but every night the survival we
had like a stint that we had to keep the
fiery light on Bear Grylls and I
remember just sitting there keeping the
fire like looking up at the stars and
we're like I'm ready for my next chapter
like I know there's another chapter
and it was just being brave enough to
then take it
and how did you know that that would be
in Media
what did you not know I didn't know no
I was I was always frustrated
from being away with England or even in
Boston that I'd see a teammate full of
Personality life and soul just this
bubbliness about him get asked a
question or being interviewed straight
after a game and go in themselves and
I'll be confused I'd be like what are
you doing that's not you like I didn't
understand so I remember just randomly
asking one of the camera guys like oh
let me interview after let me just ask
some questions and then straight away
doing that and then seeing a teammate
relax and then everyone's saying to me
Alex you know you're natural and I'm
like what's a natural I'm just asking
some questions like I don't get it
um so you don't the same thing when
people be like ah you sit in front of a
camera and talk saying I don't think
about the millions maybe that's why I'm
not sat there in that Frozen state in
fear looking at cameras because for me
the conversation is what feeds me I like
seeing people relax and be fun
um so I just started doing more of it
and then I was like right scared about
the next chapter after football
I was like what am I going to do people
trying to push me into management and I
was like it's not me I don't have a
passion to be a manager not at this
stage I've not seen myself in that role
and I was like no I need to do something
that I love that I get a passion and the
energy from and so that's why I did a
media degree I was like right if I'm
going to do this I know that I'm going
to be judged you know and I don't like
the feeling of anything just being given
to you so like no I'm going to work for
it just like I had to do my football
career I'll work for it I'll do a media
degree so I went and did that whilst I
was still playing for Arsenal
and yeah decided that in 2018
I was ready it I felt ready I had a
two-year contract on the table from
Arsenal to sign that's the comfort zone
the comfort blanket that I
I could have easily taken that I'm still
trying to pay my mortgage
I suppose most of my life is that the
fear of not having money to pay my bills
and the debt man knocking on the door
like I grew up seeing him come around
every Thursday you know that fear
about that no I can't sign that contract
I know how unhappy I'll be
did you have an alternative at that
point did you have a contract from no no
nothing there so what what is that Gap
that you know I think about like monkey
swinging through a through a jungle
you've got to let go of the last branch
and just have faith that you're gonna
grab the next one yeah what was that
period like in your life where you don't
sign the contract and then you're
looking for
your next thing
because I suppose I've always had the
fear or a lot of people what if it
doesn't work out actually I suppose I've
always been the opposite what if it does
work out I don't want to be held back in
fear of no just in case
so it's more like I knew the headspace
that I was in I couldn't sign that
two-year contract it'd be unfair it'd be
unfair to myself it'd be unfair to my
teammates because I'd just be turning up
to collect you know my monthly salary at
the end which isn't a lot nothing like
men or whatever but it was enough to be
and pay my mortgage monthly but I know I
couldn't do it it was unfair when did
your first broadcasting job emerge then
after that it's weird because I was
doing random stuff for BBC like
appearing on a like women's football
show or something and it's when I
announced my retirement that's when it
just went okay it's like I was free and
then people like well she's free to do
more she's got more hours in her day
like she can actually start doing some
work and then from BBC yeah they started
offering me more I was appearing on some
of their Flagship Flagship shows
Football Focus or kind of those ones and
then yeah I suppose 2018 for me was that
year and
because then I went off to the World Cup
2018 the first female pundit for the BBC
and I suppose from there then it
continued
you talk about coming home
um one day through that period and this
is the the part where you start talking
about this function functional or
functioning depression and you talk
about
um looking at yourself in the mirror and
then taking a walking past it taking a
couple of steps back and looking at
yourself in the mirror yeah
um
tell me about that day that evening what
happened and you end up like collapsing
and you know having a bit of a moment
yeah yeah I remember that like as
yesterday
oh yeah
I keep going back to the word heavy I
think because that's straight away I I
feel it
I didn't know well I know I did that I
was carrying a lot I'd carried a lot
through my football career which I
didn't really know I was just doing it
all trying to solve everything
straight away I took that into my
broadcasting career and like all these
great things that yes I'm the first this
I'm the first that I never set out to be
that I was just following something that
I love that I had a passion for
um
and so all the stuff and I suppose the
pressure that came with that I didn't
know I wasn't putting it on myself but
the expectation for me
the expectation I was putting on myself
was not to let anyone down like I've
been given a chance I can't let my BBC
boss down like I've got this person
that's finally believing in me he's
given me an opportunity to go to a men's
World Cup like this is big like so I was
working so much doing so much
not to let anyone down
and then ultimately on top of that
as you're becoming the first as I'm the
first female all the negative stuff that
come with that
all the trolling all the online abuse
all of that
like you've just got to a stage
where I just I couldn't take it anymore
like I'd been numbing everything
just carrying on I can't show I'm weak
if I show I'm not strong if I show my
weakness then the only thing I can't
handle it oh no issues look a female
can't handle it it's too much for her so
all of this I've just been bottling and
just carrying on putting on this face
like everything's okay
and then
that night was when it all got too much
I didn't want to come home I was
drinking to switch off to sleep to numb
it all to forget about it
and I just got to a stage where I'd had
a
dad
filled with drink an uncle passed away
was an alcoholic it's like drink problem
and alcohol has been
huge in my life and here I was repeating
those same patterns
drinking every night to switch off from
the world after work so you'd be
presenting on TV and then you'd come
home and yeah to switch off from it all
switch off um
just life
switch off from not talking to someone
don't want to speak because then I'd
have to speak about emotions and the
heaviness continues right
if I don't speak about it it's great
it's going to go away it actually
doesn't
just gets bigger and bigger
and I think it was go back to how you
said about Christmas in New Year it was
that I was on my own because it was my
choice wanted to escape everything the
feelings
and then just being so sad
so sad
and I was like I can't continue like
this
so is that choice in that moment the
next day
to Google therapy
what happened that night
just couldn't stop crying
could not stop crying drinking then the
drinking wasn't switching off what was
going on in my head
just numb just I was literally
on my bed curled up just uncontrollably
crying and I don't know why I don't know
why I was crying the way I was
and why why should I be crying because
from the outside I should I'm okay I've
had amazing football career I'm now
working on TV I can still pay my bills
like why should I be sad from the
outside world who am I to be sad I've
got everything going for me right
couldn't understand it
you understand it now
I understand yeah
that for so all my life
I'd locked up all these feelings
that I didn't know like how you said
they eventually find its way out
but we've had all these I've had all
this trauma
everyone has trauma we have a big small
everyone goes well drama and I suppose
I'd put up all this protective walls
around me
and now they're just flooded out like I
needed help
how did the trolling online
exacerbate make all of this stuff worse
and like be honest with you know we all
pretend that that doesn't affect us oh
gosh yeah no that's so easy when people
say I don't read it forget about it
like but when constantly every day
and yes my job to sit in front of a
camera
but the abuse of
you know your skin color what you're
saying just everything the pure hatred
and I'm like what what have I done
that was something like what have I done
like should I just stop
because ultimately
I was talking about something that I
love
you know I was just someone that worked
super hard didn't try and go and get a
degree to get into this world to get
another job you know to be able to pay
my bills and look after myself
and here I am getting nothing but pure
hate and abuse every single day
and I'm not going to say something I
can't do this anymore
but why
who why should I let them win you know
so I'm fighting this battle constantly
every day with myself
did that make it harder to like really
love showing up at work every day no do
you know why because like the football
cage the actual work being on screen was
an escape
it gave me like an hour and a half where
I'm doing Super Sunday that was an
escape I was actually you could forget
about everything it's straight away when
I'm going home once again that I'm on my
own that's when it all spirals out of
control
like I can't take it functional
depressive like at work I'm totally fine
put on the walls like I'm doing the work
enjoying it loving it and then straight
away then I can't take it
hence why most probably I threw myself
into more work
thinking myself time off work work
because I'm loving doing it keep it
coming Keep It Coming
yeah it's a distraction from just
sitting with oneself and and confronting
yeah I see this so much in so many
people I know this I just made myself so
busy that I won't have to actually deal
with stuff yeah it's almost like
it's almost like um I sat here with
Maisie Williams and she she'd been
through a lot when she was younger and
her with her father Maisie Williams from
Game of Thrones the the actor and um she
talked about how acting was her escape
and the interesting thing is when when
we in work and in I guess in acting we
kind of get to disassociate from our our
true self our identity like we become
this character like even me now yeah
this is obviously not you know I'm being
as authentic as I can but I'm also
trying to be a [ __ ] host of a podcast
here right so like when I go upstairs
and I'm on my own that's my truest self
obviously when the camera's on or
whatever
um but it is it's like this is our work
is our escapism it's we get to we're
playing especially when you're
presenting you are you know you ever
yeah high pitched and you're like so
um it's funny I've seen it a lot in some
of my really close friends that work is
their way of distracting themselves from
their life yeah just getting past today
but you know what maybe for me I suppose
maybe I didn't learn that part because
actually what you see on screen is
actually me I didn't learn how to either
be this presenter or be a different form
of myself so I've always given just it's
just me but who's the person at home is
the person that had dealt with all this
trauma and done stuff but had like I
hadn't
that's what I'm saying it's like so on
on TV there's this expectation for you
to be a certain way right which is
you've got to be at least you can't be
sat there talking like this yeah yeah
you've got to be a little bit up and
you've got to be more a little bit more
interested then maybe you might be
feeling but but when you go home on that
that night in particular that's probably
actually you yeah
because there's no camera there's no one
watching that's when there's no
distraction
and I think that sometimes we are who we
are when we're least distracted yeah
when there's no phone there's no nothing
go put us in a jungle and sit there for
now you'll find out who you are yeah
so like
when you are when you were alone yeah
and when you are alone and when there is
no distraction
who are you now
are you in a relationship because this
is quite no you're not in a relationship
come dating okay you're dating okay
you're dating
I don't want to put a label on it okay
here we go is the trauma you don't want
to let you wanna commit yeah that's a
toxic trait so you're dating you're not
in a relationship but you're dating yeah
okay so I'm just trying to figure out if
you're going home Alone
um yes I'd say yes I am okay yeah what
do you like now when you when you're in
that space alone
and what's the journey been like of like
being alone undistracted I love it no
yeah have you always loved it
I know what those moments have given me
in my life
but maybe because I was clouded by a lot
of stuff going on I was scared to be in
those moments where actually I think
about
the best moments that I feel now are my
most Quiet Moments so I have this
special place in Portugal and I always
escape to it because why I love nothing
more than getting up in the morning and
going on a hike in nature and I feel I
come alive like the thoughts that enter
my brain about life or what I want to do
or where I want to go like it fills me
with so much energy
so I love those moments I love going
away I go alone um away a lot on my own
and people can't get their head around
it you can is that on vacation on your
own right yeah because I need it I know
what it gives me
so like I would say those moments I love
I need it to recharge and refocus
sometimes were you ever the person that
didn't want
the party to end or didn't want work to
end yeah you were that person I had a
suspicion you might have been I've
always my labor trait those scales that
I love this end I love connection I love
people the energy that it gives me and
then I also love the other side of it I
need to be alone sometimes like not
speak and I have the conversation just
literally be in my own thoughts I say
this because
the friends that I've got closest to me
that struggle the most with unadjusted
issues were always the ones that never
so say we're on a night out a couple of
drinks one or two I'm like I'm done they
would always want to continue and it was
it was this interesting observation that
you and people listening will know this
friend they do not want people to go
home they do not want the you know they
want to have one more drink and then
they have I think someone's referred to
me before it's like the fear either upon
so but sobering up or having to go home
alone at the end of the night and I sat
here with a with a guy that kind of
explained that to me but I was just
curious if that was ever you at all it's
not that that I want to I love nothing
more than seeing people have a good time
that in those moments I often forget
that I need to have a good time okay
like I'm trying to make everyone have a
good time do you need a drink I'm gonna
go get you a drink let's go out for food
let's do this I'm planning your biggest
thing and I've never planned anything to
celebrate my own stuff because that's
what I love seeing in other people
so it's not a fear of like I want you to
keep staying out or keep giving a drink
it's just I'm loving seeing you have a
great time and that makes me so happy
the trolling stuff yeah I there's no
there's nothing more toxic than trouble
Twitter
and it's just the set it's like a
cesspool of like negativity and
anonymity and everyone's display picture
as some footballer from their favorite
club and they just say whatever people
will just say whatever I've I just don't
post onto it anymore yeah I'm kind of
the same oh what happens on my Twitter
if you look at it it's just the podcast
clip goes out and that's it yeah because
you can't vacuum yeah I don't want to be
baited into some [ __ ] but in your job
it's almost part of the job to be on
Twitter and to have a voice and to be
common like you know I see it with the
pundits like Gary and Jake Humphries and
all they always it's part of the job to
kind of mm-hmm
I would say it's part of the job for
them or but I would say to the extent
that what I've gone through with it
is maybe they haven't experienced that
level and I think I remember Jake
Humphrey saying as well lucky hasn't or
he couldn't believe the stuff that was
coming my way and you wouldn't until
you're going through it or actually see
it
like and I suppose I hit it for so long
but I tried to hide it for so long
because I was scared of being seen as
being weak not strong enough to deal
with it all
did you find anxiety
yes of
the fear of what might happen to me
to that extent
like because the abuse then would turn
into death threats also to the fact is
that I am going home alone
you know what what happens there
like we've seen in the past of you know
some presenters
what's happened
stalking all of that stuff so all of
that anxiety goes from my head like I
want to just be safe like I'm just going
to work the Jeff's talkers I wouldn't
say stalkers no
but in terms of the death threats and
everything that's and then I suppose
that's when I don't tell my mum don't
tell anyone so actually then I'm dealing
with all of this on my own yeah it's a
lot
that day so the day after the you're
crying on your bed you don't know why
you're crying yeah it's uncontrollable
and you you said the next morning you
Googled therapy therapy yeah yeah
I love because people when people have
spoken to Fair people have had
conversations about it in the past like
straight away I would screw up my face
and be like well no one can tell me
about myself I know myself like what
they're going to do they don't know
about my life
like that would be the attitude for me
for therapy until that day where I
Googled it one I didn't even know what
to look for all this long list came up
of all these different therapies I'm
like what do I need I just need to talk
to somebody
and then yeah then ended up Googling
someplace that was close to where I live
went there and it was everything that I
thought of her who would be like that
feeling of someone sitting there and
just saying yes or no to me and I was
like no this is not going to work for me
like I'm that person I need someone to
be brutally honest with me
like they're saying yes or no it's not
gonna it's not what I need to hear
were you scared when you um you went for
that first therapy session like you've
Googled a place close to you don't you
don't haven't had a recommendation
walking up to something knocking on
something like are you ready yeah yeah
yeah but it's so uncomfortable
so uncomfortable
and then went home the same thing it's
like this not gonna work am I going to
stay in this dark place get out some
wine let's drink let's numb it all that
experience didn't happen then they
actually then something in my brain was
like no
and then something clicked
that I'd heard about this place sporting
chance
actually I need to reach out to them see
if these people can help me
and then straight away within a day
someone had come back to me saying we
found this guy go and see him and the
moment Stephen I walked into the room
with him I knew he was the guy
he was the person how did you know
how he spoke to me it was no [ __ ]
his character
and you know I almost felt strange is
that I've had this relationship strange
relationship with men my whole life
but then I actually tend to gravitate
back to that kind of form
like and here it was this big man
telling me and making me see myself in a
way pushing me to see myself in a way
that maybe I've been scared to do before
and not allowing me to just be like yeah
I don't no I don't want to talk about
that no yeah that's okay
and just see me and knowing that's not
okay
this was what two three years ago almost
two and a half three years ago uh-huh
you made me start seeing that some of it
isn't my responsibility
the guilt that I'm carrying my whole
life the heaviness
making me sit in all a different way
making me see myself and learn about
myself
in a different way why I've done things
the way that I have to understand the
patterns to understand my patterns when
I need help
and that's okay to ask for help
it's not weak it's not a weakness
even we talk about like the heavy stuff
but even it's the nice stuff wanting
someone to say no I'm going to pay for
this instead of me like I I always I'm
the first to try and pay for everyone
because I just want everyone to be happy
you know like I've treated you to a meal
like it's all good
sometimes that awkward feeling don't
like it well actually no just being like
okay yeah thank you I appreciate that
you're gonna buy me dinner tonight you
know it's okay learning that
why was that a struggle
because you just kind of that's just why
not just hate awkwardness
or like now I found myself that I can
pay my bills and have you know earned
some more that I can take care of people
also so I'm trying to take care of you
where actually
I'm not earning that money when we're
talking about men's football or women's
football even in TV now but I'm earning
a salary so actually what am I doing I'm
trying to pay for everyone
like
I'm not actually I'm not made of money
but it's just that feeling that I can I
can treat you like it's good
I guess if you spend your life like
trying to help everybody else and make
everyone else happy it's coming at the
cost of something coming at the cost of
your own happiness often and
and that is difficult
you'll watch you'll see two and a half
two and a half years on now when you
when you reflect back on you know that
the person you were at 18 years old yep
or in your early you know years ago you
know playing for Arsenal and England
if you could go back and just have a
chat with her
and she would believe every word you
said
what would you say to her
that you're gonna be all right
that you're gonna be okay
but
at the same time
I almost wouldn't change any of it
because I feel like I've been
through or
so much that has taught me so much and
I'm so grateful for the lessons
so ultimately I tell her that she's
going to be okay
but you're going to go through some
stuff
but it's going to make you
even stronger
but in a different way
why would she need to hear those words
about
you're going to be all right because
those aren't the words that
most people would say to the younger
self why would why would young 18 year
old Alex need to hear those words
I suppose
it was always just a feeling of fear
and worry
so even though things might be going
okay in your football career
or you know you finally earned some
money to pay for something there's
always just you're living in a worry all
the time so it's able instead of just
rushing on to the next or thinking what
next
be more present in that moment you're
going to be okay
so just take it in I think there's a lot
I've not taken in
yeah how do you feel about your your
career in terms of
what you've achieved
everyone looking at you must think hey
Alex is an unbelievable success she's
yeah smashed everything she must be
just over the moon
I find it hard
I suppose what a lot of people do right
to hear the good stuff
like yeah like I've done all right
like from one career made it into this
career
but I suppose I'm scared to always just
sit there because it can be taken away
it can end
so I'm always thinking I need to be
better my next show I need to study my
loans I can't mess up I need to be
better so there's always that if I'm
letting someone down
so I don't think I've ever sat
and taking it all in what what have I
done
they have great like I've managed to
play for England
and now what I sit on TV and have a
conversation
I suppose I I don't take it in
when people now come up to me in the
street I I understand more I would say I
didn't understand before but now I'm
starting to understand do you feel like
you're a success
depends how do you define success
that's the great thing
are you a success in your own eyes
yes
not because of my work or that stuff
goes back to your question that you know
what I'm I've done okay
from the kid on that Council estate that
only had the concrete football cage like
you've managed to do something when a
lot of people kids from those areas
they have an expectation that you're not
amount not supposed to amount to much
so in my eyes I've been a success for
those reasons
foreign
are you happy yeah
yeah
I'm still learning to be more happy to
be honest I think I've always been kind
of happy-go-lucky person like
a feed of positivity want to hear the
good things it's you know if you've got
energy yourself around you like it
drains me I'm that sort of person so I
kind of navigate to the people that see
life in a certain way and want to have
certain conversations
and I'm starting to
yeah look at that and be more happy be
how celebrate something not big
Milestones maybe just little things you
know it doesn't always have to be the
big things but taking those moments and
yeah
if if your happiness was this list of
ingredients and you looked at it and
thought well maybe there's one
ingredient missing for me to for the
recipe to be perfectly balanced what
would that ingredient be
I would say is finally accepting love
I think I've always been scared
like I said like I've been on a journey
not been in relationships for a while
for that reason I knew that I had to do
some a lot of work on myself
like I've had people come into my life
that want to show me love that want to
give it but I've always had those walls
up no well I think finally now I'm at a
stage where I'm ready to let that in
and I think that's something that's been
missing for my life
and what do you want from that from the
next chapter of your life
what is the you know because you look
forward and
10 years from now we say oh God that was
a successful chapter what happened
to be I would say be more present in the
moment
really is like it's weird because I
don't ever look like five years or ten
years people's in terms of like my next
job or anything people like well what
show do you want to be presenting in
five years I think I've always been I'm
quite spiritual but I've never like I
might have these small goals
but I'm also open to that actually I
might go right a bit and it might I
might learn some lessons here to push me
in that or open to
that you might have an idea of that's my
presenting goal I need to be on that
show but actually because I'm on this
path it might take me a totally
different way and I'm I'm okay with that
same like the football decision
you know do I sign a two-year contract
in my Arsenal career I've actually do I
listen to how I'm feeling
and it's taking me on a totally
different path
I wonder if there's a bit of a like the
survival mindset in there where like
it's just okay I hear this a lot like
I'm just trying to make sure I don't
lose this [ __ ] to do my best today so
thinking about the future seems like a
waste of energy because I want to make
sure that you know
because I'm because there's sometimes a
fear in US of of going back and I think
I think people that have come from
harder times understand this a little
bit more I think maybe if I if you'd
come from a privileged place you
wouldn't have you wouldn't have ever had
a fear of like what happens if I lose
this contract because you can just you
know fall back on the safety net of your
like parents mansion
but there's more of a like a fight in
the moment I see which ends up I think
as you've described it like deferring
our happiness because we're just trying
to get through today we're not enjoying
it we're just trying to [ __ ] hold on
here you know
oh I'm scared of that yeah like a fear
of like losing that contract but I also
have a fear of standing still hmm like
just being okay like being not just
average like I always want to be better
than I was yesterday
but you must have dreams big
no yeah like dreams of for me like
owning a house in the area that I am now
because I know I love that area yeah so
isn't dreams of like when I went into
the TV career like there's a select
group of people that I'm like oh if I
like get into that category like I know
I've done all right because that's how I
view them like Top Class same like in if
we're talking football terms when you're
playing for England you're the best
right back you know like I want to be in
a category where I see those presenters
that you know they are top class
right so I suppose I keep working
towards trying to be seen at that level
which I think for me is hard because I
don't know honestly if I'd be viewed
like that why
because I already have
a perception
around me
that I've just been given a role
right
that I'm tick in a box
so I think that perception now for a lot
of people like that's always going to
stay with me no matter how hard I work
or have work to get to where I am
that's kind of a perception
makes you upset doesn't it
because I I've worked so hard
people can't they see just sometimes the
end process of it or they don't see that
or the whole process what's actually
taking you to get to that
which like I'm fine with but the fact
that
like yeah you're not respected for the
work that you're doing or been done
that's hard for me
when you say people think you're there
because you're taking a box what box do
they think you're ticking female
black
quota
you why do you carry that yeah
goes back to another thing that's heavy
it's been heavy
it continues to be every time a
subject's brought up because maybe I've
been that first to them breakthrough
it's like I am that spokesperson or you
know we'll go to Alex she needs to speak
about this
so it's just it's just always there
always
and it's like as if it's become my it's
me it's my story and I'm like no there's
a whole lot to me you know going on in
my life I'm not just being trolled
but that's how now people would either
just see me
or all the abuse or yeah this
I didn't see it like that thanks didn't
even write down trolling on here I
didn't was was completely irrelevant to
obviously who you are so
it's interesting that you were carrying
that that in your mind but it didn't
cross my mind I didn't even think we're
going to talk about it today
I don't consider it to be part of your
story thank you
not even saying that to make you happy
like if I I just didn't think it was
it's not it's not anything to do with
you is it it's actually someone else's
problem
in every sense of the word
I suppose it's when you're getting phone
calls every day
about that or straight away that that's
constantly every
thing that you read online yeah it's
that yeah
there's this interesting thing when you
when you represent an unrepresented
community that it ends it ends up
becoming like your personal brand so
like as you've said oh we need to talk
about black issues or women issues in
football so microphone Overture and it
and and it's
that's on one hand the right thing to do
because other people shouldn't really be
speaking on those issues but in another
way it's um it's kind of the wrong thing
to do because it pigeonholes you as a it
reduces your identity as you've said
down to just like black woman when you
are so much more everyone else is
allowed to be so much more yeah but
um people don't really think about that
they think they're being kind yeah or
thoughtful or considerate how do you
know what I suppose like in terms of
there's parts that I find it hard
because like I said before I also
understand my responsibility more with
it where before it was just I was just
finding a job I'm just sitting on a sofa
having a conversation like oh this is
great actually what I didn't understand
me sitting on a BBC One show so far a
flagship program for BBC is actually
doing for a lot of people I didn't
understand that until maybe there was
one time that I'm riding back through
East London it's actually during the
pandemic I'd rode from like North London
to East London to see my mum and riding
home there was two black women on a park
bench and they were shouting at me
Stephen and I was like well what's going
on here what's going on in there like
like family yeah basically pure joy that
they'd seen me yeah and they just told
me keep going
nothing more and I was like wow it
touched me yeah because of all the stuff
you see online those two people on that
part bench I understood what I'm doing
what's your relationship like these days
with your father
no it speaks for him
when's the last time you spoke to him
2019
and it wasn't a conversation it was a
text message
the last time I'd actually spoken to him
was my Nan's funeral in 2017.
I remember standing on the balcony and
whopping
it had some drink
but him telling me that he knows
he's not been the person that he should
have been and he's carried a lot of
regrets and he's going to change
and I was already so distraught because
my nan was one of the closest people in
my life
but I remember just feeling like I I
don't care if you do then great I'd
spent my whole life sending him
Christmas presents birthday presents
ringing him just to check in because I
had this guilt that he would be lonely
or
and then from that moment
I was like now I'm done
like I didn't hear from him so I'm not
going to chase him like once again it
was just this that it's just all talk
like I'm over it
and then I was doing strictly in 2019
and I got to Blackpool strictly was like
this bubble of happiness that
at a stage I'm like I just needed it and
it gave me that strictly did
and then I remember I got to Blackpool
and I was on the train on the way up
sitting next to Michelle Visage who's
this character who I'd never thought I'd
have someone in my life like her and who
I am opposite end she's from New York
but we just had this connection she was
my person on Strictly
and she saw my phone Flash and she's
like what the heck what's that she must
have seen something in my face and it
was a message from my dad asking for
tickets
to come to Blackpool I hadn't heard from
him the 10 weeks I was on the show
um
and I asked for tickets
not for him though
for two of his friends where he lives
you know what our team
the Elton John film and I remember
crying in the movie theater because
there was a part in that that I was like
geez that's how I feel there was a part
um Elton John he was just trying to
connect with his dad the whole time
and then there was one point where the
dad reached out to him and was like come
around for dinner or something and when
he turned up it was literally just for
him to sign all graphs
so there was no love or he didn't really
want him to be it was just a sign
autograph for the kids he had around the
house and that's how I felt in that
moment
like it wasn't you didn't care about me
I'll ask how I was or you wanted
strictly tickets
for your mates
but I remember I had the courage to
finally write back to him that's wrong
and I think it must have touched him in
a way because I'd never done that like
if I was mad or felt angry about
anything would never tell my dad because
I always still had that fear
um
and so he must have known and then
straight away you text back apologizing
that oh no it's just a he's way to try
and connect with me to ask for tickets
and they were really for him and I was
just oh this is just [ __ ]
and as I'm not spoken to him since
but I'm gonna have to
uh and I want to speak to him
you're not finished talking yeah
it's on one hand
like I've done this book to free my mom
on the other hand I'm scared that it
could ruin my Dad's life
and I don't want that
so I need to plug up some courage
because yeah I need to tell him
that I've wrote about
stuff that's not going to be comfortable
for him
we sit here on
the 9th of September yeah but comes out
in 10 days from now on the 19th of
September
are you are you thinking of speaking to
him before the publication or after the
publication no before
I think it'd be very wrong if it's just
out there and I hadn't spoken to him
like I've not wrote the book I I didn't
write it to destroy his life or make him
seem like this person and I truly hope
he's not that person anymore like people
change
so I don't want him to be judged on
that in the past like I want people to
tell you for who he is now
so I want him to understand that I've
not wrote it from a place of being angry
with him or
that ultimate it's not about him
it's about wanting my mum to break free
of it all
so what are you thinking I was just
thinking a few things I was thinking
it's a it's a difficult conversation and
I've got to be honest I
there's a part of me that thinks you
don't own that
this this is my look it's not none of my
business but there's a part of me that
thinks you just you don't own that as
you said it's not it's your story and
it'll impact people you love of course
and then
um I think you have the right to speak
on your own experiences regardless of
how that might make someone else uh uh
who's played that kind of role in your
life feel I just don't know I just you
know that's easy for me to say it's not
my dad yeah you know I you know so but
that's that was what I was thinking
I think yeah that's called back and
forth in my mind like I don't need to
right he's not been there in my life
I would say you sit in there
having this conversation with me you
know me better than my dad
like he doesn't know anything about me
can't describe me as a person doesn't
really know what's going on in my life
doesn't know so yeah I don't own that
but it's I don't know something in me is
telling me it's the right thing to do
for him is my dad I love him did you
ever understand
the cycle that he's in that made him the
way he is
no
I think that's where I always
think that's something like he must feel
the guilt and the sadness
you know and that's why I've always
there's a good person in there
like something's gone on that's made him
feel like this or
I don't know if it's me just making up a
story in my head
but I feel like I always saw that from a
kid
like everyone has good in them you know
I'm still trying to pluck up the courage
it's coming around soon I've got to do
it
so yeah
I will do it
you finished this book by um writing a
letter to your mother yeah yeah
that was hard in the audiobook I'm not
gonna lie yeah spell that whole chat to
crying
why am why did you want to end the book
in that way
the book
shows her
that I am me because of her
that she's an incredible woman and
everything that she's done
has allowed me to be in the position
that I am
and for her to understand that she
doesn't have to be the strong one
anymore
I I I'll do everything to look after her
and just to enjoy her life she still has
this life you don't need to be trapped
by the past anymore she's still trapped
by it
that yes like me taking him out for
dinner or a theater show like to try and
give her that happiness
like I can only do so much
I'm hoping that letter sets her free
that's why
oh
no it's beautiful what you write about
her and it was actually it's actually
difficult to read it because it's so
beautiful and it's so it comes from such
an authentic place so I can't imagine
what it's like having to say it in a
booth into a microphone when you're
doing the audiobook I can't imagine even
reading the words were just so you could
feel that the words were so intentional
every word you selected in that letter
is so um
so intentional so it's um it's moving
for someone that you know has never met
your mother but um thank you what an
amazing daughter she has raised thank
you
so it does actually it does actually
make me smile going back to one of your
questions about I don't know being proud
or like even seeing you just have that
book like that's my book yeah like
I wrote my own book like I didn't even
go to school like education it was a
struggle yeah dyslexic the speech was
like they're all there all the problems
in my life
but I actually just sat down on my
laptop laptop and wrote that book and
like you just like you've got it there
like I don't know it still doesn't feel
real but I'm just like yeah I did that
you did that I did that
Alex we do have a closing tradition on
this podcast yep which is where the last
guest leaves a question for the next
guest and they don't know who they're
writing it for oh
you will also be asked to do the same
which is leave a question for the next
guest and again you won't know who that
guest is but and I don't get to read it
until until the very end of the podcast
so oh okay it's very very easy to read
what is
your deepest fear
good one at the very core of you what is
your deepest fear
my deepest fear
is my Mom leaving this world
and not experiencing happiness
that
is the fair
though I actually need more from me no I
was just thinking about it it makes
sense because you've explained you've
explained it you've explained it that
you've seen this kind of numbness in
your mum to the world and you're it
feels like you've been fighting to try
and solve that yeah and as you've said
this book is part of the solution in
your eyes to liberate her from that she
wanted to be happy
and it's a smile more
take a moments and just not think
something's gonna happen
just for her to have some happiness
do you think she has to go and walk some
of the same
steps that you've walked in terms of
therapy and going back to do that yeah
yeah
I don't know how hard that's gonna be
for her
because you're going to bring up
rawness the stuff that she's tried to
push to the side
But ultimately
I know it can free her
but she has to have a willingness
hopefully
I think that's there's a power in there
isn't there I think this is what I I
hope when I get sent about I hope the
book sets are free
because I know there's so many people
that have gone through the same stuff as
my mum
and I think maybe
if she understands that and sees that
that they're free or they've come
through things
that maybe she can start to be on that
Journey
so there's there's a huge fear the
answer to the question
But ultimately I look forward and when I
look forward I see there's a light
and I feel that's where I smile because
I'm just hoping and I pray that that's
where she's getting that's where she
gets to
Alex thank you thank you for having me
thank you it's been an absolute pleasure
um you're a wonderful person and I know
this is just the start of our
relationship so yeah thank you thank you
Stephen oh someone get me a tissue
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]